welcome back to new rock stars i'm
whitney van laningham and my biggest
question after watching the multiverse
of madness is did scarlet witch get
scarlet squished or was she somehow able
to survive an entire temple collapsing
on top of her it certainly wouldn't be
the first time that she lived through
impossible odds including the explosion
that killed her parents and the
torturer's experiments from hydra but
will we really see 616's scarlet witch
again or is rwanda dead in the aftermath
of the multiverse of madness premiere
elizabeth olsen has been busy giving
interviews about the fate of her
character back in march rumors were
circulating that she'd extended her
contract with marvel and although she
didn't explicitly state that she had she
did tell collider that she doesn't see
this as the end for her character and
hinted that her mcu contracts are always
adjusting in another interview with
variety she seemed super excited for the
possibility of returning to the screen
saying it's weird that i'm expecting to
return but no one's told me i'm doing
anything but in my mind i'm just making
the assumption that they'll have me
again i don't know to what capacity but
i hope i'm back i hope there's also more
fun to be had in something different
where do we go i feel like we've done so
much with her it's been really a wild
couple years with her if lizzy's down to
keep going i am too so let's talk about
what those different fun directions
might be wanda maximoff is one of the
most powerful and fascinating characters
in the mcu and with the immense success
of wandavision she's become one of the
most popular characters in the entire
series not only is she the only avenger
who could have single-handedly defeated
thanos a rare wielder of chaos magic and
the scarlet witch she was also the only
being in the multiverse powerful enough
to take herself out even strange wong in
america knew that there was no way to
physically stop her they could only
continue to reason with her until she
made the choice on her own and if she's
capable of all that i'd be willing to
bet that she was able to keep herself
alive at the end of multiverse of
madness too but let's look deeper at
some of the evidence i think it's
totally possible that wanda will return
this wouldn't be the first time that
wanda was presumed dead in marvel
history in fact in the house of m
storyline which multiverse of madness
draws inspiration from wanda disappears
after altering reality to remove all
mutants from the world she's presumed
dead and doctor strange even suggests
that she may have taken her own life but
hawkeye later finds her living in mount
undergore with zero memory of what
happened or that she even had powers at
all and it makes a lot of sense for them
to make it seem like wanda is gone in
the mcu too with her off the chessboard
marvel has time to build up newer larger
threats in her absence the scarlet witch
could pretty much take out anyone so
with big bads like gore and kang on the
horizon they needed to take wanda out in
the multiverse of madness to keep things
interesting kevin feige knows his timing
and in my opinion i think her death was
the best way to move her story forward
when wanda destroyed the temple at
wundegar in this film a large red flash
of light shoots out of the actively
decimating rebel and while you could
arguably view this scene as confirmation
that the scarlet witch's life force was
extinguished from the 616 reality i also
think that there's a valid argument that
this flash of light proves she's still
alive at every single pivotal point in
her life thus far wanda has protected
herself even if she didn't realize at
the time that she was intentionally
doing it for example when agatha makes
her relive the night her parents died
she notes that wanda subconsciously used
a probability hex to prevent the bomb
from going off she protests saying that
the bomb was just effective but agatha
continues to point out further instances
of her doing similar things she was also
the first test subject of hydras to
survive direct contact with an infinity
stone and her love for vision
unintentionally created an entire town
to soothe her own broken heart agatha
points out that her chaos magic
amplified by the mind stone allowed her
to survive these experiences and i think
it's possible that she survived this one
too whether she meant to or not i think
that that red light signifies her chaos
magic protecting her yet again and if
she does come back in future marvel
properties we could find her lost in the
ruins of mount undergore without her
powers or her memories just like they
did in the comics you never want your
earbuds to fall out whether you're just
walking the dog exercising or bumping
around the house blasting your favorite
episode of the dungeons and daddies
podcast without your loved ones being
like whitney ron stampler isn't a real
person recon's everyday earbuds have
optimized gel tips for the perfect fit
it makes them comfortable and they don't
budge thanks to raycon for sponsoring
this video
holy diver you've been down too long in
the midnight sea
wow that totally worked look at them
look at them they're still in my head
they're still firmly in my head raycon's
everyday earbuds look feel and sound
better than ever they offer 8 hours of
play time and a 32 32-hour battery life
that's long enough to listen to the tale
of four dads rescuing their sons from
the forgotten realms raycons are priced
so that you get quality audio at half
the price of other premium audio brands
it's no wonder raycon's everyday earbuds
have over forty nine 5 star reviews and
they come with a 45 day happiness
guarantee click the link in the
description or go to buyreicon.com
new rockstars to get 15 off your recon
purchase once again go to byraycon.com
new rockstars for 15 off there have also
been rumors floating around that wanda
might appear in house of harkness
alongside her nemesis from westview but
elizabeth olsen stated in an interview
that she doesn't think that she signed
up for that series judging by the way
she's enthusiastically expressed her
openness for other potential storylines
i'd say she's not garfielding here for
example in an interview with
comicbook.com she said that she'd really
like to see a storyline where we see the
scarlet witch as an aging woman she said
quote there are a few images in my head
of i think they're from witches row and
she's aging into kane while using her
power and there's something in that this
older woman who's aging from her power
that i'm interested in and i don't
really know what that means but i kind
of would love to be old elizabeth olsen
also seems extremely interested in doing
more with the house of m storyline even
saying quote i do think doctor strange
too opens up lots of opportunities with
the multiverse but yeah the immortal
words are no more mutants i mean i would
love to be able to say them in some
capacity to make it work for the mcu and
i know i know this is an actor
discussing hypothetical work that she'd
love to be a part of not an official
confirmation from kevin feige that this
is definitely gonna happen but she said
it herself mom really opened us up for a
lot of possibilities for what could
happen to her character in the future so
i'm not taking wanda reappearing for
more of this story inspired by house of
m off the table playing a version of
herself that's stripped of her abilities
or has her powers redefined in a new
context might give the scarlet witch the
ability to come back to the 616 verse
without forcing fans to just forgive and
forget the destruction she caused as of
right now it's a little hard to get past
the murderous rampage she went on in
multiverse of madness but if wanda were
able to start over in the 616 with a
clean slate seeking to regain her
memories and understand the destruction
of her powers that could be the perfect
way to show her taking responsibility
for the lives that she claimed follow me
on instagram and twitter whitneypuppy
follow new rockstars subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you